هابقى معكم مشاهدينا في تحديث اخير
للارقام اداره الكوارث التركيه تقول
ارتفاع عدد القتلى الى
3703 حالات والجرحى الى
22,286 ينضم الي من باريس جون فرنسوا
منظمه اطباء بلا حدود مرحبا بك سيد جون
هناك تساؤلات عديده في هذه اللحظات حول
كيفيه وصول المساعدات الى المناطق
المتضرره هناك دوله ذات سياده وهي تركيا
يمكن الوصول اليها بالتعامل مع الحكومه
التركيه ولكن ماذا عن سوريا هي منقسمه ما
بين مناطق قادعه للنظام ومناطق اخرى خاضعه
للمعارضه
هذه مشكله ملحمه
من حيث ارسال المواد ومواد الدعم الطبيه
الاخرى الى
الشعب السوري
لا بد لنا ان نجد بعض الطرق التي يمكن من
خلالها دعم شركائنا المحليين
في سوريا
والعمل على تزويد المواد
والمستلزمات الطبيه في الميدان
اننا نشره ببالغ القلق بزب بسبب
الطبيعه
الاوضاع السياسيه في سوريا بحيث لا يمكن
ايصال المساعدات الى بعض المناطق وكما
تعلمون في مناطق الشمال في سوريا
هناك ايضا اماكن يصعب فيها ايصال المواد
فضلا عن مشكلتي وجود المياه النظيفه
لذا فهناك اكثر من مشكله فضلا عن مشكله
الكوارث الكارثه الكارثه التي ضربت البلاد
فهناك الاوضاع السياسيه
ومن خلال
احاديثنا من مع مسؤولي
منظماتنا كن كنا قد طلبنا بتطوير نوع من
الاتصالات مع السلطات السوريه
وماذا كانت نتيجه هذه مع الاتصالات هل
اعربت الحكومه السوريه عن السداديها
للتعاون
مع تخضع للمعارضه ستسمح بعبور لهذه
المساعدات عبر منافذها
في المرحله الحاليه من الصعب ان نعلم
ما هي الاجابات من قبل السلطات الموجوده
في في دمشق وهناك مناشدات من تركيا ومن
دول اخرى كانت قد وجهت الى السلطات في
سوريا من اجل السماح بادخال المواد
وهناك فريق موجود في المنطقه الجنوبيه وقد
تدرب على العمل في سوريا وعلى المناطق
الحدوديه
التركيه السوريه هو اننا
متاكدون انهم سوف يستطيعون على ايصال
المواد اذا ما سمح لهم
وسوف يحاولون ايضا ان يقدموا الدعم الى
المستشفيات بالمواد الضروريه والمواد
الطبيه والعمل على الدعم النفسي كما
اخبرتكم
لابد من وجود اتصالات
بحيث يتم ابعاد مشاكل الخلافات السياسيه
والامنيه
والتركيز
على سماح لجزء من فريقنا للتوجه الى
المناطق المنكوبه وخاصه ان فريقنا مستعد
للقيام بهذه المهمه لكن في ظل هذه الظروف
الصعبه لا استطيع ان اؤكد بان الامر سوف
تكون سوف يكون بتلك وكيف يمكن
السلطات في سوريا ان تسمح بايصال هذه
المساعدات لكننا سوف نبقي على طريق نفس
طريقه العمل التي اعتمدناها ابان الحرب
بابقاء
المواد وكافه
اللوجستيات جاهزه
لاستخدامها عند الحاجه اليها
المنظمه العريقه منظمه اطباء بلا حدود في
ظروفك هكذا مع طقس سيء مع صعوبه في المرور
على الطرق كيف كان يمكن توصيل المساعدات
في اصعب المحن الى المحتاجين لديكم خبره
في هذا المجال
نعم ان الاوضاع صعبه للغايه
فالاجواء
الاحوال الجويه السيئه فهي تزيد من مخاطر
ايصال
المواد والمساعدات السلطه التركيه لديها
طرق متدربه
تعمل يدا بيد مع الهلال الاحمر التركي
وعلى ايصال المساعدات وخاصه في مناطق
الجنوب التي
بدات تعجب باعداد الجرحى وكانت تركيا قد
طالت دعما دوليا
وتم توجيهها من قبيل كافه المواد
والمعدات الطبيه لمساعده
المستشفيات والمنشاه الطبيه لكن الامر قد
يستغرق وقتا وسوف يكون محفوفا بصعوبه
والسلطات التركيه سوف يكون لديها ردود
افعال سريعه على عكس نظيرتها الموجوده في
سوريا فيما يتعلق في تقديم المساعدات في
ومما يزيد الامور صعوبه هي الاحوال الجويه
السيئه بحيث النظام الطبي قد يكونوا في
حاله شلل بسبب سنوات طويله من الحرب
وهناك مشكله النازحين الذين كانوا قد
عانوا معانوه لسنوات طويله من الحرب كما
قلنا سابقا واننا نشعر بالقلق ازاء طريقه
كيفيه
تفعيل الانشطه المطلوبه في سوريا لدينا
شركات مع بعض الجهات المحليه في سوريا
ونسع من خلالها الوفاء بكافه الاحتياجات
الطبيه والانسانيه لكن الامر الاكثر صعوبه
ايضا بالنسبه للسلطات تركيا هو تنظيم
المساعدات الدوليه لان
عندما تكون يكون اعداد الاشخاص الذين هم
بحاجه لمساعده كثر فقد تبدا الامور لتدخل
بحاله من الفوضى وتظهر حاله من التوتر لان
اناسا كثر هم بحاجه لتنقل هذه المساعدات
لذا فان الحكومه التركيه مطالبه بتنسيق
بتنسيق هذه المساعدات بالتعاون مع
المنظمات المجتمع المدني
لكافه هذه المساعدات ومواد العون التي
تاتي من الخارج والعمل على تنظيمها بشكل
جيد
في اجابه مختصره هناك رقم صادم عرضات
الامم المتحده اليوم منظمه الصحه العالميه
انه ربما تصل نتيجه هذه الكارثه اعداد
المتضررين قد تصل الى 20 مليون شخص وهذا
رقم كبير للغايه
نعم
الناس الذين يعانون سلفا من فقر متقع
ويعانون من القيود المفروض الى درجه كبيره
في الشمال السوري
يعجز الوصف عنها فهم قد تاثروا بصوره
مباشره
وخاصه
اولئك الناس الذين فقدوا منازلهم
فحجم المساعده والعون
الذي ياتي
اليهم من الخارج يجب ان ينصب الان
لانه قد يستغرق فتره طويله فنحن لا نتحدث
عن ايام او اسابيع بل اطول بكثير لدى الاب
قد تكونوا ثلاثه اشهر او اكثر لذا فان
المساعده يجب ان تبدا بحيث يتم تتم
الاستجابه لهذه الاوضاع الانسانيه
لانه للاسف قد يستغرق الامر عده اشهر لتصل
الى بعض المناطق التي يصعب الوصول اليها
من اجل عودتها الى حالها الطبيعي وايصال
المواد الغذائيه وغيرها ولهذا السبب فان
المساعدات التي تاتي من منظمات مثل اطباء
العالم التي يجب ان تبدا الان من خلال
برنامج اغاثي الذي لن يحل لن يدخل الى حيز
التنفيذ خلال بضعه ايام بل سوف يستغرق
اشهر والا
وان لم نسعى لتسريع فان اناسا كثر سوف
يفقدون
كثر من اقاربهم او احبائهم فهناك تحديات
كثيره
ولابد من العمل على تسريع الاستجابه
لهؤلاء المتضررين
وخاصه في خلال الاسابيع والاشهر القادمه